pouvait m'apprendre sur vous qu'on
connaîtrait pas et qui sera intéressant
c'est parce qu'il serait intéressant que
j'aime pas le boudin par exemple quand
se pose est souvent la question
l'intérêt est il une valeur morale avait
traduit et ce qu'il avait raison quand
quoi où quand
quand ouais alors pardonnez moi de vous
dire que quand je vois pas qui c'est
[Applaudissements]
bonjour chanter un champion dont vous
appelez nabila je fais un petit résumé
de votre carrière donc vous aimez bien
le shampoing ouais j'aime tra voilà
pascal praud a déclaré à l'issue de la
rencontre psg marseille
la pelouse était humide et vous
alors si votre copain était un dessert
ce serait plutôt un mystère une
religieuse ou un gland comme quoi un
gland cesser le gâteau vert avec des
trucs qu'on longe comme ça quoi un gland
ne connaissez pas mais non je connais
pas un gâteau qui s'appelle un groupe à
ce jeu vous en offrir avec plaisir ah
non ça c'est super bon c'est comme une
religieuse au chocolat et crème anglaise
de d'empêcher serait c1 grâce à des
trucs qui tombe des arts donc c'est un
gâteau je parle bien sûr pas un gâteau
aucun un gâteau à un moment il ya un
autre va chercher chercher sur internet
y a pas on fait comment bah vous me vaut
que si la page vous parlais justement
quelle question que je pose souvent et à
tout le monde en période électorale
euh vous embêter mais ce que j'étais
j'étais en train de regarder mes tweets
alors c'est quoi le dernier par exemple
on est on est curieux vous me suivez pas
sur twitter vous voulez que je vous
suivre sur twitter même je vous suivent
sur twitter
nous avons tous les travaux déjà je vous
promets vous avez pas vous avez pas la
tête à voir plus tard je vais peut-être
avoir quoi alors je sais pas lire
l'express le monde
vous avez déjà un fax depuis 15 jours
parce qu'avant je renvoyais tout par la
poste ou tanger un fax la paix qui sait
qu'il fait ça genre du troc aux plantes
j'en ai pas beaucoup donc ils seront
donc peut-être qu'ils ont de toutes
petites salles mais moi je leur lis moi
je vous envoie un fax mais faut se
mettre aux mails vous voyez ah ouais
c'est important parce qu'il faut que
vous me parlez des trucs préhistorique
c'est une période électorale que pensez
vous des candidats sans étiquette
candidat sans étiquette
ça veut dire quoi sans étiquette aux
coups bas sont pas une étiquette
ouf est ce qu ont perdu qua non à partir
de quel moment un livre n'est pas un
livre
bah ça c'est c'est un peu compliqué pour
moi non mais sur le magazine esquire
magazine peut être un livre ou pas ah
non un livre aille à un via les grands
livres il ya vingt pages là et lé petit
livre les magasins sa défense de la
taille d'un magazine avec plein de pages
on peut considérer sans un livre bah
ouais voilà bah écoutez bas je tais toi
ouais je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]